So these are some of my favorite kids.
My godson is the one with the Rubik's Cube.
My niece and nephew there.
So around 2050 these kids will be in their 30s.
Which, if you have kids that you know,
this will be true of them also.
So I want to walk you through some of what's projected
for the Earth system around 2050.
And this isn't primarily based on climate model
predictions like we're used to
this is looking at extrapolations of
what's happening to the system now.
It tends to come from scientists and researchers
that are looking at different parts
of the system individually.
Firstly we have a projection that
the amount of forest burn area in the United States
will be 10 times what it was in 1970.
Today it's about three times what it was in 1970
So it's tracking along with temperature rise.
Two or three decades from now we can anticipate
lots more forest fires than we have today.
Alongside that going on at the same time
we will have the effects of heat on the ocean.
And one that we hear a lot about is
the heat effect on coral reefs
Coral reefs support 25% of life in the ocean.
And currently they're being killed by heat stress.
They're sensitive to heat. Big heat waves are coming.
We've lost somewhere between a quarter and
a half of the coral reefs in the world already.
And they support a big portion of ocean
life.
So we don't know yet quite what happens
when we lose that life.
The ocean is a really complex,
highly  interconnected system.
Heat stress on the ocean could have effects that we can't fully predict
in terms of what happens to other life in the ocean.
And the links between the ocean and the atmosphere.
There's a form of life that grows at the surface
of the ocean called phytoplankton.
That biological life is important to feeding fish below.
It also handles interaction between
the ocean and the atmosphere. I call it the API layer
between the ocean and the atmosphere.
It sort of interprets what's happening in the ocean.
It's produced by the the ocean food web.
And then it interacts with the atmosphere.
It takes in CO2.
It releases gases that help form clouds.
And it's very important to our system.
Currently phytoplankton we're losing at a rate of about
1% per year. Or, sorry, a decade.
And it's thought that since 1950 we may have lost
as much as 40% of the phytoplankton on the ocean.
So we have to watch for things like this
in terms of the whole system.
Another thing we have to watch for is
collapse of ice sheets in Antarctica.
This is a picture by Chris Michel.
Chris where are you?
Who has many wonderful Antarctic pictures...
and he can talk to you about what it's like
to go to Antarctica many times.
If those ice sheets were to collapse,
as they are predicted when temperatures
approach around 1.9°,
then we might see some big changes
some big abrupt changes in sea level rise.
And in the nature of the current circulation in the ocean.
And the major AMOC
(Atlantic Meridional Overturning Circulation) current.
These things are predicted to happen around 1.9°.
As we saw in a previous chart we're looking
at that around the middle of this century.
Based on what's happening.
Concurrent with those things
we have effects on infrastructure.
One of the things to think about when
you think about climate change
especially when it comes to discussion of adaptation
is we're likely to have lots of things going on at once.
And a lot of our infrastructure was
built to a certain range of conditions
of temperature, of wind, of storm surge, of
ground conditions... and we're starting to push
the climate outside of the conditions that
some of that infrastructure was built for.
Tthese are two charts. The chart on the left
shows the vulnerability of bridges in the United States.
It's forecast that by 2050 about half the bridges
in the United States will be vulnerable.
Meaning they need to be reengineered
or they shouldn't be used.
Half the bridge in the United States.
And the other chart is looking at the vulnerability
of coastal military infrastructure.
Which is something that the military
takes pretty seriously.
You can see an enormous amount of vulnerability
to flooding of that infrastructure
possibly rendering some of those sites unviable.
Those are just a couple of examples.
I'm not here to necessarily raise alarms.
But what I want to do is say can we think rationally and logically about
the set of conditions that we're facing.
And the kinds of options that we might need to look at.
Because heat stress is something
that creates a number of
big changes and big challenges concurrently
that could lead to a lot of suffering for people.
And a lot of irreversible changes in our natural systems.
Good news: we're in Silicon Valley.
And I'm lucky because I know
the head of research at the SLAC.
And lots of people in venture capital.
And people at Stanford
at the Precourt Institute (for Energy)..
And Berkeley where they're working on energy solutions.
And the things that are coming down the
pipeline in terms of energy and materials,
capturing carbon... are extraordinary.
I'm a techno-optimist.
And I believe that by the end of the century
it's absolutely possible that we could have solutions to
waste, to energy, to food production
that allow the sustainable, healthy, happy life
for people on this planet for years to come.
And big natural systems that sustain themselves, too.
So the question is... how does that look
in terms of the timeline to our solutions?
So this is a chart that's based on IPCC information
and the United Nations environmental program showing
what we would have to do
to maintain temperature below 2 ° with
the tools that we have at our disposal today.
Based on emissions reduction alone we would need
to start moving to zero emissions by 2030.
Which is 12 years from now.
In order to stay below 2 °.
Zero emissions. Zero net emissions by 2030.
That doesn't look very likely
based on what it takes to transition
energy production and other things.
So the IPCC has introduced the notion of
removing carbon from the atmosphere.
So actively finding mechanisms that can filter the air
bring down carbon.
Finding more ways to actively plant organic materials.
Trees and other things that will
pull carbon out of the air actively.
So what they've done in IPCC projections is
they've said if we have these things
then it is possible to extend the time that we have
to safely stay under 2°.
But you'll notice from the chart
that these require starting to implement
these negative emissions technologies
now. And scaling them up very rapidly.
And the folks in and around the IPCC will admit
that these things do not exist yet.
And they haven't been fully analyzed.
Even the notion of planting trees more aggressively
in a certain type of way
in order to increase their CO2-absorption.
So we have a challenge
that we have a pipeline of capabilities
that in the future could lead to a zero emissions world.
And a way that we can reclaim
greenhouse gases from the air.
But we don't have them today.
Typically it takes about 50 years
to transform infrastructure and replace it.
So we have some period of time between today
and the future where we have
a disruptive set of technologies that we need.
We're right in the middle of that
that time span that we talked about
around the middle of the century: 2050.
We have a bit of a problem because that's
when big system changes might occur
that create a lot of suffering for people
and potentially set off reactions that we can't control.
you